How do you find purpose?
What does it mean to live with intention,
and why is it so important to cultivate stillness?
These questions are important.
The answers are elusive,
and they can only be found
by essentially knowing where to look.
Well, "Knowing Where To Look" also happens to be the title
of the new book by today's guest, Light Watkins,
dropping in today for his third appearance on the show.
Light, in addition to being a good friend,
and a beautiful incarnation of the human form,
a nomadic minimalist,
is and has been for the last 20 years,
a lotted meditation and spiritual teacher.
He's also a prolific public speaker,
the founder of something called The Shine,
which is this really groovy event series.
Think Ted meets self-realization.
And the author of three books, "The Inner Gym,"
"Bliss More," and of course, his latest,
"Knowing Where To Look."
This is great talk about stuff that matters.
I think you'll enjoy it,
so hit that subscribe button
and that notification bell thing.
And as for knowing where to look, you're in the right place.
So without further adieu,
please enjoy me and my friend, Light Watkins.
Good to see you my friend,
it's been awhile.
I know.
I can't remember the last time we crossed paths,
maybe a couple years?
Yeah, I think I saw you actually
on your birthday at Cafe Gratitude.
Yes.
When you turned 50, I believe.
50?
How old are you now?
Dude, I'm almost 55.
Couldn't have been that long ago.
You'd turned 53 or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember that.
I remember that.
Pre-pandemic, Cafe Gratitude.
You were wearing all black,
a bunch of beads.
(laughing)
Hair was longer, no beard.
A lot more hair.
So that helps
to narrow down the time around when it was.
Your were with Julie,
and I think it was just you and her.
I think it was just, or maybe the kids.
Maybe one of the kids or,
I don't remember.
Yeah, pre-pandemic though.
Yeah.
You've had an interesting-
I was already, like on the road at that time,
so I happened to be back in LA just randomly.
Right, so you've spent the last year,
well, initially you were in Atlanta, right?
Before going to Mexico city?
Yes.
Or did you go back and forth?
I started off the pandemic in Atlanta,
then LA, and then back to Atlanta,
and then back to LA and then Mexico City.
So I was actually in each of those places
for like about four or five months.
There was a little bit of a LA exodus to Mexico City.
I have like three or four friends who kind of
have been riding out the pandemic down there.
Yeah, it's a great place to ride it out.
How did you decide on Mexico City?
I had been hearing about it for years,
and then when I went nomadic in 2018,
I started going to Mexico City here and there
for a couple of weeks, three weeks.
And it's like,
it's kind of like being in Europe
without going to Europe,
'cause you're still in Central Time Zone in the US,
and it's just beautiful, you know?
It's just everything, it's green.
It's very walkable.
The food scene, the cafe scene is amazing.
The service is impeccable.
Like everything is great,
and the dollar goes a long way.
Right, it's affordable.
Yeah.
Well, I'm fascinated by this nomadic lifestyle
that you've been pursuing.
I suppose, I guess this is part,
it was kicked off by kind of the third purge
that you've done,
'cause this is not the first time
that you've explored this.
(laughing)
There's a part of me that's jealous,
like what it would feel like to just be that free,
to live out of literally, you know, a carry on,
and be that kind of malleable and mobile.
Well, it's interesting because you know, I'm in a,
normally when you hear that sort of story,
you probably imagine someone in their 20s, you know?
Or maybe in their early 30s at the latest.
Meanwhile, I'm about to be 50.
(laughing)
So it's a little different in that in this life stage
because my peers are all like
they're really establishing serious roots.
Some of them are even grandparents at this point
or kids out of college.
And so there's not a lot of people who I grew up with
who can really relate to what I'm doing.
So you really have to be, you know, sure of yourself.
And into the idea of it.
I've kind of been that way my whole life,
so I don't really know any different, but yeah,
it's been an interesting journey.
And I tell people who are intrigued by it,
I was like, look, you know, I'm not,
my example is not to go
and sell off all your stuff and, you know,
jump on an airplane overnight.
Like it took years of experimenting
to get to this point.
And so for me, it just kinda felt like a natural extension
of what I was already kind of doing.
I mean, I was already prior to 2018, I was traveling,
I was going to London every month or so,
I was going to New York all the time.
So I started challenging myself
to see if I could live off of whatever I could fit
into my carry on bag for those two weeks or three weeks
I was gonna be on the road.
And then after doing that for a couple years,
then it was like, okay, well I know I can do it.
I've practiced it enough, let me go ahead
and sell all this other stuff and just commit to it.
But there's a difference between knowing you can do it,
and reckoning with whether it's the right thing to do.
I suspect you must come up against moments of loneliness
or self-doubt with this.
100%, I mean, you know, you spend a lot of time
on your own, but then that's where the meditation
and all the inner work kinda kicks in.
You know, I've been doing that for 20 years,
and I try to tell people, you know,
help people understand that that's been
a part of my journey as well.
And one of the primary benefits of all that daily meditation
is you become more self-aware,
you become more comfortable with your own company.
You enjoy silence, and you know, and I can be as,
you have to also be relatively outgoing
if you wanna find a social life in these different places.
So, I mean, you know, I can kinda dip in
as much as I want to.
I consider myself to be more of a introverted extrovert.
Like I can do the extroverted thing,
here and there if I want to,
but I'm very comfortable with my own company as well.
So, and I'm busy, you know, I'm writing books,
and I've got a podcast
and I'm teaching meditation trainings,
and organizing retreats.
So it's like, I almost spend a lot of time,
it's kinda like when you and I first met at that hotel,
The Ace Hotel in the Flatiron district in New York,
you were, this was midnight.
I was there doing some work and you were there doing work.
You know, and I was on the road teaching,
but after hours I was like writing my book,
or I was thinking I was marketing my first book,
"The Inner Gym."
And you were there
editing an episode.
Yeah, I think I was
getting a podcast off
Writing an episode.
Or something like that.
I was in search of internet.
And that's kind of, my life is,
you know, I'm so passionate about things that I do,
that I just kind of busy myself very easily.
And, and we've had conversations about that.
Like there's no such thing as work-life balance
when you're really passionate about what you do.
Yeah, it's so deeply integrated.
Well, there's a difference between
getting rid of all your stuff and going on
some kind of walkabout versus
living your life intentionally,
being clear on what it is that you're doing,
what you're seeking and being purposeful in,
how you kind of approach
that very different type of lifestyle.
Yeah, and I consider myself to be one of the lucky ones
to have kind of centered in on a mission
that I'm very, very excited about.
Like I literally wake up in the morning
and I can't wait to get to work,
and thinking about ideas and spit-balling,
when I'm just walking around and so
every spare moment is really an opportunity
to kind of tweak and refine,
and then you add social media to it, right?
And then it's like, okay, well,
I'd love to put some kind of messaging out there
you know, I want to get this quote in my head.
So I gotta tweak the quote,
and then I gotta turn it into
a quote card on Instagram,
and then an audio, that's
like hours and hours.
Are you doing
all that yourself?
Doing all that myself.
Yeah, all myself.
I mean, the idea is not to continue doing it
all myself all the time,
but it's kind of how I iterate.
Like I have to get my hands dirty.
I have to roll up my sleeves,
and see how things work.
And I'll get so many more ideas
of how to communicate more efficiently,
and optimize the process just for myself
from just doing it myself.
And then eventually I can explain it
simply to someone to help me.
And that's kind of how that works.
Yeah, through the doing,
you see the path, you know,
the path is revealed ahead of you,
which is a big kind of message in the book.
Yeah, and it's all storytelling, right?
And that's really what people connect with the most
is whether it's an Instagram caption,
or a tweet, or a daily dose of inspiration email
that I send out, it's all stories.
And it helped every time I sit down and,
especially when you have limitations,
like I was telling a friend of mine,
he said, your daily doses,
these emails that you send out every day,
they've gotten shorter and shorter.
And I said, well, yeah because
now I want people to be able to like screenshot them
and share them a lot easier.
So I intentionally keep them
within a hundred or 125 words if possible.
Sometimes it's not possible.
But I also followed up with,
it's harder to write a short email.
Much harder.
Than it is to just let my thoughts rip
and just not edit it as much.
So it actually takes longer
to truncate it and keep it succinct.
And also, to put it through all the screens
that you're very familiar with, you know,
'cause this is like you put out
some really heartfelt, vulnerable post about your journey.
And then you get the one, like person commenting
about how you didn't include their little situation
was overlooked.
And it's like, no, he probably thought about that.
I'm sure he thought about it.
Five levels deeper than anyone
who's commenting on his posts,
but you can't accommodate
for every little exceptional situation.
Yeah, brevity is not my strength though.
You know, the economy of your lifestyle in some part
perhaps fuels your economy of language,
you know, everything is being kind of,
it's like the the path gets narrower.
And when you know, read the words
of the sages and the Buddhas, it's always very short.
Like there's a clarity in that
that comes through decades
of wisdom acquired through experience.
Yeah, I mean, that's one of my mantras is,
if you can't, it's the Einstein quote,
if you can't explain it simply,
then you don't know it well enough.
And so, and that's why I've really come to embrace
reminders, because in reading things over,
the same things over and over and over,
cause you just, you see them differently each time,
and then you're understanding them in a deeper level.
And then it gets distilled down to its essence.
And that's really where it becomes, you know,
almost magical in its application and utility.
I feel like that
you're taking advantage of these very powerful tools
that are available to us,
that allow us to uncouple geographic location from vocation.
In past decades to kind of, you know,
live the minimalist lifestyle,
and be a nomad would be, you know,
akin to Kung Fu you know, kind of wandering into towns.
And there is an asceticism that's built into it,
but you're still able to do all the things
that you would be doing
if you owned a home with a picket fence
and had, you know, a car in the driveway.
Yeah, and in a way I do still have those things,
I just don't own them myself.
I'm just using other people's.
Right.
So where are you, where are you staying now?
I'm staying in Mexico city.
I just have an Airbnb that I live in.
It's like a beautiful two-bedroom.
It's just like I had a two-bedroom in LA.
So I think people have this idea that I like to,
I'm drawn to tiny houses and it's like,
no, I actually like space and I like things.
I just don't need to own them myself.
And fortunately you don't need a car in Mexico city.
And I'm just, I don't even know how long I'll be there,
but everywhere I go, when I'm in London
I'll rent an Airbnb somewhere,
or you know, New York, what have you.
And I kind of prefer places
where you don't need to be driving so much.
But in Los Angeles, I had to stay with a buddy of mine,
who's got a beautiful place, and I rent a car.
And so, you know I make it work.
You're able to be in the modern world.
Yeah, very much.
You're not adorned robes,
walking barefoot down Abakenny.
And also, you know, I'm on,
I'm on stage and I'm speaking to them, you know?
So it's like, I can't look like
I'm living out of a backpack.
I want it to look like you don't even know
that I'm living out of a backpack.
That's something that's happening in the background.
And, but yeah, you're right.
I mean, it does help me practice brevity
in all areas of life, because you just, you have to.
People always want to like give me things,
which I think it's very, very sweet,
and I have to remind them.
I say, look,
it's nice that you want to give me this little token
or this little thing or book or whatever,
but it's like I really don't have any room for it.
You can imagine how many people
give you this little thing and it adds up.
So, so yeah.
But it's not personal if you have this general rule.
No, it's not.
But I imagine it must have been hard,
you've talked about this a little bit,
when it came to, okay,
I'm gonna do this thing again, I'm gonna shed,
and you're getting rid of like all your journals,
and all these kind of very personable memorabilia
that we're kind of hardwired to collect.
There must be a sense that,
once you've done that, like a feeling of lightness,
but do you ever think like I wish I hadn't like,
those are things that when I'm old I'd like to look at,
that maybe could have provided the foundation
for the next book,
or are they all scanned and in the cloud,
so you still have them.
I put everything
in the cloud.
I scan every page of every journal,
So I have everything and that's what's great
about modern technology is that we can do that.
And, you know, and in a way it's even more accessible now,
because now I can categorize it, I can label it all.
And it's all in my
my file storage application.
So I can just go to it in a couple minutes,
and I've actually looked at those things a lot more
than I ever did when it was just collecting dust
in the back of my closet.
So, you know I think that's something
that people should do anyway
is scan all of their stuff in,
so that they can at least access it whenever
they're with somebody from their past.
And they're like, oh wow.
You know, I have these photos of us
from like 20 years ago,
and you don't have to go and dig for it,
and wonder where it is,
and which box you put it in and this kind of thing.
So that became,
and also I kind of worked
the logic on it.
And I said, look,
when someone writes a memoir
or when someone,
or when someone dies, right?
So even someone prolific like a Steve Jobs,
the guy who created the iPhone, when he dies.
How many photos of Steve Jobs
have we seen floating around out there?
Probably a dozen, right?
Maybe a couple more than that.
But you could imagine
he probably had a kajillion photos somewhere,
but we only see like a dozen
and you can apply that to really anybody.
So the point is,
if this stuff is going to become used at some point later
you don't need that many.
You know, you don't need your whole catalog.
No one's gonna sift through all of that stuff.
But, but if you have kids,
then you just start hoarding like crazy numbers of photos.
Yeah.
If you have kids, you know, in 20, 30 years from now
and they want to see old pictures,
and it's all categorized,
and they have the passwords and everything to your files,
then they can see everything a lot more efficiently
than like digging through and wondering, what is this?
Where is this from?
So it's kind of a way to organize it a little bit better.
Yeah.
Well, even though we haven't seen each other in a while,
I've been paying attention
to kind of everything that you've been doing
over the last year when the pandemic hit.
And there was this social permission
for everybody to just kind of stop
and stay at home and do nothing
and not feel guilty about it.
I feel like you've been incredibly productive,
and in many ways really found your voice,
like in a new gear
with all the stuff that you started putting out,
those videos on Instagram,
which were, are, continue to be
like so well thought out.
And every time I look at them, I'm like,
is he reading off a script?
Is he just spontaneously like delivering
these incredible monologues
that are so clear and concise
in their point of view and thinking?
Yeah, I've been pretty open about the fact
that those were all written out, and rehearsed
and, you know, again, I wanted to keep them
within like a minute,
maybe a couple of minutes at the most,
but really it was just to value people's time,
because I know that when I just speak off the top of my head
I have a tendency to drag on and on and on.
And, and I want it to be as concise
and as clear as possible.
And so my process was I would, you know,
what you're referring to
is I made a vow to myself
when I was in Mexico city in February 14th, 2020,
right at the right at the very beginning,
I made a vow to myself to post a video a day on Instagram.
And the reason was
because I wanted to practice speaking on camera,
and I'd been already writing
my daily dose of inspiration emails
and sending those out for four years.
So I had already been used to
to generating inspirational content,
'cause that's what happens when you do something every day,
is it starts coming through you.
And so now I was just kind of applying it to video form,
but I didn't want to,
sometimes I would borrow ideas
of things I'd already written.
Sometimes it would just be things that came through me
and I would speak on that.
And so it wasn't really about, you know,
anything more than just practicing
and then come April, May
when the George Floyd thing happened,
it was literally just another day.
And I thought to myself,
okay what am I going to speak on today?
I'm literally sitting on my couch in my Airbnb in Atlanta,
and I wanted to go to the park and go for a run,
but I hadn't shot my video yet.
And it usually is like an hour and a half
maybe two hour long process,
depending on how clear my thoughts are.
And I was doing everything myself.
I had learned how to caption, how to put headlines.
It takes like, the process was like three or four apps,
before posting it.
And I thought, you know,
this thing that happened to George Floyd,
people probably exclude me from that category of person.
Like obviously I'm a black person,
but a lot of my my non-black friends, I think,
see me in a different way
than they would look at someone like George Floyd.
And I said, this is a great opportunity
to communicate that actually
the things that happened to him
have also happened to me,
maybe not as extreme at this point in time,
but it could go in that direction
if I'm in the wrong place the wrong time
with the wrong cop and all of that.
And so I spoke to that, you know,
cause I'm from Alabama and a part of being from Alabama,
which was the staging point
of the modern civil rights movement.
You know, that's a part of the ongoing conversation,
in all-black families is black people, white people.
This happened to us and this is what we have to do
and get to work harder and all these kinds of things.
So I just talked about a few instances
where I had been racially profiled in my life
all the way up until most recently, you know,
when I was marketing my last book, "Bliss More,"
the meditation book,
I had been pulled over by a cop in LA,
because the cop had received a call
that I was looking to break into someone's car.
And I'm going to a book interview to do a podcast.
Oh my God.
But some person saw me,
and I was looking for my friend's parking space.
She said, you can park your scooter behind my car.
So there are all these numbered parking spaces.
And I can't find the parking space.
And so somebody thought I was like.
Like casing-
Casing the whole parking lot to find out
whose car I was gonna break into.
I'm on a scooter meanwhile,
like, I don't know where I'm gonna,
what I'm gonna carry on a scooter.
You're a scary black man.
But I'm a scary black man.
I had a suit coat on and everything.
So anyway, those kinds of things have been happening,
and it's almost, up until that point,
it was unremarkable.
Like, you know,
who am I gonna complain about it to?
Or that's gonna really care,
or is not gonna say,
oh you know, that was just coincidence.
But it happens all the time.
Not all the time, but it happens often enough,
that to my black friends, like, oh yeah, of course.
To my white friends, it's like, well, you know, okay.
And so I talked about those instances,
starting when I was like seven or eight years old,
all the way up until that point.
And that video, you know normally I post a video,
get maybe a few thousand views.
That video got 3.5 million views.
I was like, wow.
I guess people want to hear more about this.
Well, I remember seeing that video,
and then watching your daily videos,
and just getting this sense that you,
because you are this guy who,
you're the meditation mindfulness guy,
and you really exist predominantly
in kind of this white wellness culture.
That's where you've made your mark
and what you're known for,
but in the wake of George Floyd,
you really stepped up and met the moment
in a meaningful way.
And it's not a surprise to me that those videos,
have traveled in the way that they have.
And your demeanor in speaking about it is
I think a product of
the decades of meditation that you have.
You're able to speak about these things
with a degree of equanimity
and objectivity while making your point
but in a manner that
is digestible to a large audience, I think, is that fair?
Yeah, I realized I was actually
uniquely qualified to speak on it,
because I'm black, so I had that experience.
But then also, like you said,
with the meditation and the wellness stuff,
like I almost had like a way to kind of speak on it
from a 10,000-foot perspective,
instead of the ground level perspective
where everyone's like heated and emotional,
and there's a time and place for that, obviously.
And, I think it was also important
to just relate to it from a little bit further out,
and show, you know,
there are some connections here,
in a way that the people who follow me,
which is primarily white people,
'cause that's who I was really speaking to.
I wasn't speaking to black people,
because black people don't need to be told
about racism and all of that.
And then I got, you know, you get a lot of comments like,
oh, I've never thought about it like that.
Oh wow, you know, I need to go and have a conversation.
And it's like, well no,
this is how you have the conversation.
'Cause otherwise you're gonna reject,
you're gonna have people be defensive and whatnot.
So yeah, it was an interesting time,
and I felt very, it felt very organic for me.
It was almost like, you know,
if the world wanted to talk about ultra-marathons
and it's like, whoa.
Suddenly in recovery.
It was like, well Rich has a lot to say about that.
You know, I applaud it.
You know, it was like, oh,
he's really, he's stepping up to own a space.
He must be feeling on some level
like he's getting out of his comfort zone,
but it was so clearly not just the right thing to do,
but the right thing for you to do,
like it felt like you were very comfortable doing it,
even though it departed from kind of
the way you normally operate.
I mean, I remember one video you made,
was called something like,
"for white people asking what to do about racism."
And I watched that,
and I think about that video all the time.
And I would have to tell you that,
I credit that video and other videos that you've made
with how I started to, you know
rethink how I'm approaching the moment.
And that was a big motivator
in our decision to go to Minneapolis the other week,
and have those conversations that we've had.
So, you know, if you ever questioned
the efficacy or the effect of what you're doing,
like, I can tell you that I'm personally grateful for it.
Thank you, man.
Yeah, it was interesting because I also,
I didn't want to,
once you go viral with something,
it's obviously tempting to kind of feed into that,
like, wow, I could, you know,
like my whole follower count doubled and everything.
I had to consciously choose
to continually being organic with it
and not try to force, you know, these topics,
'cause I knew that they would be very popular.
I wanted to, 'cause that, I think that's one
of the reasons why it resonated initially
is because I wasn't trying to become popular.
I wasn't trying to go viral.
I was just speaking openly and authentically.
And so it was just a really interesting opportunity
to kind of go back within
and still maintain that level
of what I felt was authenticity
throughout the whole process.
And I'm honestly, I'm kind of,
it was nice to get back and talking about things
that weren't necessarily directly tied into all of that.
Because again, that's been an ongoing conversation
in my consciousness for as long as I've been on the planet,
and ultimately,
it's not my issue to solve, you know,
or even to give all this perspective too.
I think ultimately it's something
that needs to be worked out with white people.
And I'm happy to kind of give the impetus
for that conversation to take place,
but what will make me really happy
is to see more white people just
initiating that conversation with other white people,
and just kind of talking about it,
and hopefully, you know,
getting other people to talk about it
and just having the conversation more and more and more,
because I kind of started feeling
like a broken record after a little while.
Yeah, well I think,
I think those conversations are happening.
I think more white people are engaging in that
in a more meaningful way than they have historically.
I think a lot of white people feel paralyzed.
They're so terrified of getting it wrong,
that it prevents the conversation from even happening.
And there's a permissiveness
to the way that you kind of speak about it
that provides that, that kind of opening
I think that allows people to feel a little bit
more comfortable engaging in it,
knowing you're not gonna get it right,
or being okay with misstepping, as long as,
in good faith, you're grappling with it
in a way that perhaps could have some kind of impact.
I dunno, man.
What's your sense of all of it now?
I mean, it's been a year.
We came back from Minneapolis a couple of weeks ago.
You know, and part of that,
even if the trial wasn't going on,
like it was something I wanted to do,
because there's this sense like, oh, well,
we did the George Floyd thing.
Like now we're past that.
And like, now we're good, right?
And it's like, no, this is something
that's gonna take a very long time.
Like we have to keep having it.
But at the same time, are we belaboring it?
Are we sounding like a broken record?
Like finding that balance I think also.
Well, I think, yeah,
I think that's the shift that ultimately needs to happen.
I would, I can't speak for all black people,
but I will speak from my own experiences.
I don't like having,
I'm like anybody else,
like I have a book it's coming out.
It's about inspiration.
I have other things that I'm excited about.
And every time the police,
or there's some situation that occurs, right?
It's almost like as a black person,
you have to stop and you know,
start talking about that, and say her name,
and you know, all these kinds of things.
And it's like white people have the option to do it.
They don't have to do it.
They can do it if they want to.
But ultimately, you know, as a black creator,
you kind of have to at least acknowledge it in all.
See, it's like you have to figure out ways
to thread in police brutality
with talking about art of inspiration.
Well you did it in the book.
I mean, you tell the story
about you and your brother as kids,
and the sort of legacy of that,
and how these experiences recur
over the course of your lifetime.
And you just learn to assimilate, you know,
to that reality on some level,
but that this is nothing unique.
Anybody who's living the black experience knows this well.
Yeah, and you know, that's just part of what you do
as a black person.
So, but you'd like to see it with other people as well.
You'd like to see people take it as seriously
when it happens, you know, to anyone.
And, but, you know, it's a big world.
People have a lot going on.
And, and so it's gonna take time, I guess,
but we have to keep talking about it.
So I'm glad we're talking about it here on this podcast.
I'm glad to talk about it with you.
I'll talk about it as much as you like,
but we also want to talk about,
we want to talk about the book, right?
Let's do it.
"Knowing Where to Look."
You did an extraordinary job with this book.
I love it, it's beautiful.
It's as much, you know, an art book
as it is a book book.
It is a bit of a choose your adventure type thing.
You can crack it open to any page.
And it's one of those things where like,
oh I didn't know that this is what I needed today,
but this is exactly what I needed to hear.
The artistry behind it is very cool.
As you said, there's like Easter eggs in here.
And the layout, you know,
is what you've done
with like font and typeset and all of that,
and graphic design, all kind of feeds the themes
that you're trying to express.
And it's all oriented around these
108 essentially like anecdotes/lessons/stories,
and 108, of course, being this spiritually relevant number
that permeates Hinduism and Buddhism.
And is this, you know, a metaphor for
unity and wholeness and any number
of other mystical factors that apply
to that specific number,
including the number of beads on any Mala
that you drape around your neck.
Yeah, the initially, you know obviously
there was a conversation around 365, one a day,
but I didn't want the experience to have a linear,
even an accidentally linear approach.
I wanted, I really wanted people to
to feel like they could just start anywhere.
And even if they needed to revisit the same one,
it's almost like one of those magic eight balls,
from when we were younger,
where you shake it up
and it's got that little blue liquid,
and then the answer to whatever your question was
would come into the little viewer.
And so I wanted it to have that kind of feeling
and level of engagement with people.
And I feel like we've succeeded in that.
We painstakingly went over every single detail.
Like there's literally no detail
in any of those pages that we didn't
at least spend a few hours going over
and talking about how we can really
bring the meaning through the design,
and the way the text is shaped and all of that.
So I want it to be like this little adventure
that people may not discover what's hidden in there
until they've read it two or three times or more.
And it is, you know, it is about brevity too.
Like it's not, you know, they're simple stories,
but they're powerful lessons.
It's a book about all kinds of things.
Kindness, patience.
Relations.
Reflection,
relationships, gratitude, trust, faith.
Everything we struggle with.
Small gestures.
Compassion.
Everything we struggle with
on a daily moment-to-moment basis.
Almost anything you're conflicted with right now,
if you crack the book open,
you can probably find,
and I tell people this is not about giving you the answer,
it's just a little nudge
to maybe look in this direction or look behind you.
And that's where you'll find
your own answer, your own solution, within yourself.
If there is a meta arc or theme to it, though,
it's in my mind a book about
inspiration and courage.
The opening of the book with this story
about your decision to go to Paris.
That's an amazing story.
How, you know, the universe conspired to support you
at just the right time.
And it's sort of faith and courage in motion.
And having that level of conviction
about that at a young age I think is interesting
and kind of foreshadowed the life to come,
even if you are not consciously aware
of how it would play out.
Yeah, I wasn't consciously aware,
but obviously in hindsight,
I feel very fortunate to have had that kind of experience.
And in such an obvious way.
So what you're referring to is I was,
when I graduated college,
I had a nine to five job for a few months,
realized right off the bat
this is not really for me,
or it's gonna be here later.
So I may as well, you know,
do something else, see the world, exercise freedom.
And I had this calling to go to Paris,
and there was nothing really more to it than that.
And I spent my last little money
on a one-way ticket to Paris.
Not really knowing anyone there,
not speaking the language,
just really a leap of faith in every sense of that phrase,
and landed in Paris and ended up,
on the first day, ended up running into
some friends of mine from college.
Hold on, I'm going to interrupt you,
And we got to back up a little bit,
'cause there's two things that immediately pop
into my head that I want to know more about.
And the first is,
the impulse, the germinating impulse
to even do it in the first place.
Like what was the, you know,
conscious awareness around that?
Like, it was this knowing,
like you just had to do this thing.
You knew on paper, it was kind of insane.
You didn't even want to tell your mom what you were doing.
You told her you had a job in Paris,
but you had this compulsion
that you couldn't ignore
that motivated this whole thing.
Yeah, it was a thought that would not go away.
And now I realize that whenever you have a thought
that feels charming to your heart,
and it doesn't go away,
that's an indication from the universe,
in quotes, "the universe,"
to move in that direction.
It doesn't mean that you're necessarily
meant to fulfill that completely,
but just take a step or two in that direction,
and then the next instructions will come to you
once you start moving in that direction.
Sure, it's one thing to have that sense,
and it's another thing to trust it,
or to take action on it.
Especially as a young person
who's got all this social programming around,
like you got to get the job and here's what you do,
and this is how it's gonna play out.
So there's something about you
that I think is unique in your ability
at that young age to have that cognizance,
to be able to recognize that as the opportunity
that you needed to follow.
Well there was some fear there too, you know,
like I wasn't all courageous and like, you know,
like I definitely was skeptical.
I definitely had doubts.
I definitely didn't know what was gonna happen,
but I had been
testing the waters
with following that voice,
for a few years prior to that,
even in university, I remember I was,
I had been awarded,
I applied for and campaigned for this job
as the editor of the yearbook in college,
which was a very prominent position,
because you got paid,
you got a great parking space,
at Howard University in Washington, DC.
And,
and I did that my junior year.
And so the expectation is, once you do it,
and now you've already had the experience under your belt,
of course you're gonna do it your senior year.
Why wouldn't you?
Right?
Right.
But I decided, something told me not to do it.
And instead to go and explore,
like working on Capitol Hill and doing these other things,
taking photography classes and all this other stuff.
I listened to it, and it was great, you know,
and I don't know what I missed out on
from not doing it,
but you know those kinds of decisions I've been making,
just kind of,
and I guess a part of that was
not identifying success with money
or with prominence or with titles.
And I feel like I consciously
had been questioning all of that for a long time.
And so when it came up again after college,
and I was at that job, you know,
I decided to leave the job,
because
I didn't equate my success with
rising up through the ranks of that advertising agency.
And so it was just kind of an extension of all of that,
if I'm looking back at it now.
But you know, I like to speak about these things
in ways that help other people access
the same kind of thing.
And I wasn't meditating, or I wasn't doing,
we're talking in the mid-90s now,
so there was none of that happening.
But I do remember intentionally
just testing the waters and questioning, you know,
if this is really making me happy,
or if this path is going to lead
to some sense of fulfillment within,
and so on paper,
or if you pull the lens back on my life at that time,
it looks like I was kind of all over the place.
You know, I was trying this and trying that.
But really I was just trying to taste
different colors of life, define, okay,
what's the path for me?
And it happened to be taking me to Europe.
Right.
For a period.
You go to the airport,
you've got like a couple of hundred bucks right, that's it?
Yeah, nothing.
And a backpack.
And the flight's oversold,
so they start doing an auction, you know,
who's gonna give up their seat.
The auction ratchets up to 400 bucks or whatever it is,
and you opt for that.
So before you've even left
you already have taken care of your return ticket.
Yeah, I got two of those, two days in a row.
Another signal from the universe,
okay, this might work out.
You go, and you meet people on the airplane?
In the hotel.
In the hotel before you left.
Who had the same seats as well.
So you already know people who are going to Paris
who are Americans before you even go,
so you have some kind of grounding foundation.
You go to Paris,
you interview for a job you don't get.
But down the hall is like your college friend
that you didn't even know lived in Paris.
There's like all of these crazy-
This guy looked at me
in that first office and says you know,
what happened with you and this job?
And I said, I didn't get it.
And he was American, he was from Chicago.
He recognized before from Chicago
He recognized my photo.
From some modeling.
Yeah, from some modeling thing I did.
He recognized me.
He happened to live in Paris, and he was from Chicago.
And he was in the office that day, that morning,
in the first place I went once I landed,
and I told him, oh, I got rejected.
And he said, follow me.
And he took me out of that office
on the same floor of the same building
down to the next office right next to it,
and we walked in,
and then we saw my friend from college,
who turned around and goes, oh my God!
What are you doing here?
He didn't know that she knew you?
No.
So she's like bananas.
She just happened to be there.
She wasn't working there, she just happened to be there,
with her friend who happened to have a spare apartment
because his mom had just left town
to go visit his sister.
And he said, where are you staying?
I said, I don't have a place yet.
I literally didn't have-
It was the same day that you arrived.
It was the same morning.
It was within two hours of arriving.
And I had an apartment,
I had friends.
I had two vouchers for $400 for a flight back.
I mean that's a powerful lesson.
You're like, okay.
I had everything.
This trust in the universe thing,
if you do it right, maybe, you know, this is the way.
Yeah, and that's the whole through line of the book
is really to follow your heart,
take the leap of faith,
which is where the courage part comes in,
because it requires,
it's not about getting rid of the fear.
It's about practicing the little things,
taking little leaps of faith,
whether it's, you know, go right instead of left,
when you're going to work,
or whether it's drive the car or ride the bike.
Like these little moments where
something inside of you is saying,
hey, maybe you should ride a bike today.
And just listening to that.
And once you do it enough times in the little ways
then it'll start to accumulate,
and you'll be able to do it in bigger ways.
Yeah, it really is about those little decisions,
those little moments,
having the awareness to be attuned to them when they occur,
so you can course correct.
I mean, when I reflect back on my own life,
like the huge changes that I've made
are the product of small decisions
or having enough awareness in a particular moment in time
to know this is where I pivot this way,
and those pivots are very slight.
You know, when we think about things like inspiration and
following your passion and all of these things,
we think about sweeping grand gestures,
but it doesn't really work like that.
And I appreciated in the book
how you really, you know,
were mindful of noting that it's not about that.
It is these little things
and those little things will,
are things that I think are visited upon all of us.
So it's really a function of how aware you are,
and that, cultivating that awareness
always goes back to these practices
that you've been teaching and practicing yourself forever,
the mindfulness and the meditation.
Yeah and it's not even just like, you know,
things that light you up inside.
It could be like,
like on the way here to this interview,
I was parked, my rental car was parked in Brentwood,
and somebody sideswiped it
and ripped the side view mirror off,
and all of these things.
Normally, when you walk back to your car
and you see that you're like, shit!
Now I have to like deal with all of whatever that entails.
But I tell a story in the book about
being stuck in this traffic jam
on my way to teach yoga one morning.
And it was like this phantom traffic jam in west Hollywood.
It was at a time where there's never traffic
on Fountain Avenue.
So I'm like zigzagging around the Santa Monica Boulevard,
and trying to find the shortcut, 'cause I'm running late,
'cause I didn't give myself enough time
to account for a 15-minute traffic jam,
end up showing up at class,
10 minutes late, and then turns out,
right at the top of the hour
when the class was supposed to start,
this wall mirror, floor-to-ceiling, wall mirror,
somehow dislodged and came crashing down,
right where I would have been sitting,
starting the yoga class.
So they were in there sweeping up shards of mirror,
broken mirror, on the floor,
and all the students were in the back of the room.
And I was like, whoa, that traffic jam
that just spontaneously appeared out of nowhere
was actually saving me, potentially saving my life,
or saving me from having a very bad start to my day.
And so I learned from those kinds of experiences,
that even when someone sideswipes your car,
you know, and I didn't do anything,
I wasn't like parked illegally or anything like that.
I was just, it was a normal parking spot,
but it's like, okay, well evidently
my path has taken me in the direction of
having to file a police report.
And who knows what's gonna come from that?
So there's almost a sense of anticipation almost,
where you have enough of these kinds of experiences.
And it's like, wow, it's almost like,
because it's taken you off of your normal schedule,
it's almost like, okay, what's gonna happen?
What kind of cool adventure?
What kind of cool things
are gonna happen from this?
This is not happening to me, this is happening for me.
I don't know how or why,
but that will be revealed in time.
And if you can just shift your perspective in that way,
it could allow you to find a little bit more presence,
and be a little bit more open
to whatever those opportunities could potentially be.
So that's been my experience and that's, you know
like getting rejected from that job in Paris.
Like if I've been all sulking
and not wanting to talk to anybody,
I wouldn't have been open to the guy coming up to me
wanting to take me to the place
where I was gonna get
all of the apartments and everything else.
So it's like, it's almost like
you can't judge a situation
based on what whatever's happening.
You just have to go with
that flow of whatever it is,
which sounds again very simplistic but it's-
Very hard, it's so hard to do.
It is, it is.
Just to maintain neutrality.
God really?
This is like interfering with my plan.
That's why the book is called "Knowing Where to Look,"
'cause it's like, even in those situations,
the answers, the solutions, are there,
if you know where to look for them, you know,
so I want people to be able to use it for those purposes.
When you're having a bad day,
for whatever reason,
usually the bad day
is a result of things not going your way.
If, you know, kind of,
if I read that story about the mirror crashing,
then it may allow you to release that,
that negativity around the situation
and just kind of like settle into it and be open to it.
And you never know what's going to happen after that.
And that's, what's exciting about life.
Yeah, you mentioned, you know,
if you had been sulking after that initial interview,
and I think that's a key thing,
because it's about the energy
with which you carry yourself,
like how you're reacting or responding
is, directly correlates into how you're being with yourself,
and how you're being impacts,
how you're interacting with other people
and how they're going to react to you.
You tell a story in the book
about how you engage with this flight attendant,
and you go out of your way to like
shower her with praise and thank her for her hard work.
After being angry that she was bugging me.
Right, like to take that contrary action,
and then to get this amazing result.
And I think that's really powerful.
And it reminds me of an experience that I had
when we were in Minneapolis.
So our kind of Sherpa
boots on the ground friend of mine
who helped make this trip happen and was,
you know a really wonderful host to us
when we were in town.
His name was Brogan Graham.
He been on the podcast before.
He's the founder of November Project.
Have you ever met him?
Do you know him?
No, never met him.
He's an extraordinary guy.
I mean, there are extroverted people,
and then there are Brogan-verted people.
This guy is so extroverted it's like off the chain.
And he has a practice of
not only carrying himself
with just unbridled positivity and optimism
in everything that he does,
such that it's become constitutional to him.
But he makes a point of going out of his way,
I mean you can't walk down the street
without this guy going up to every single person
and asking them how they're doing,
and engaging in them and saying we're new friends,
and like exchanging phone numbers.
Like it's exhausting, but it's also,
it's a really powerful lesson,
because all of these people
leave those encounters feeling better,
because he's given them a little bit of love.
He's funny, he's a comedian,
he's like super present and engaging.
And it was kind of a Marvel to watch him do that.
And at one point, I think it was Jason asked him,
does anybody just like, shine you on?
And while he's like all the time,
he's like, it doesn't matter.
He's like, it's just taking hits at bat.
Like I'm just, I'm getting more swings.
It's a practice, it's a practice.
I show up for it.
And one of the other things that he does is rather than,
and I've started incorporating this
into my life as a result,
rather than texting people,
or when you're in a text conversation,
he sends people what he calls short films.
Like he'll just make a video
and he'll just talk extemporaneously
about something and he'll tell a joke.
And he just sends that,
there's no expectation that you have to get back to him.
And there's such a difference when you get one of those
you feel much more connected to that person.
And I've started doing that with some friends,
and it's been a really cool experience
of flipping that equation of like, oh, I'm too busy,
or I don't want to text person back
or doing it to somebody you haven't talked to in awhile,
and they just get a little movie, you know,
in their messages app, out of the blue.
And it makes me feel better.
And I just feel like it's a practice
that I want to continue to cultivate.
It's just an example of the story
that you told with the flight attendant.
A hundred percent man.
And I tell people, you know,
'cause people will hear that and go,
oh, I'm not that kind of person.
You know, I could never do that,
but what's your version of that, right?
Like maybe it's a voice note.
Maybe you draw something
on your drawing app and you send like,
there's different ways.
You can, maybe you sing a song,
different ways for different people.
If it resonates, if it kind of like
tingles something in your heart,
then that's a sign that you should not ignore,
that you should find your way of doing that.
And the only way to do that is to start doing it.
Not to overthink it, but just to start doing it
in ways that make you uncomfortable.
And then eventually you'll kind of hone in
on what makes you comfortable.
Well the subtlety of it,
the tingling can't be confused with the fear,
because it does require you,
to do something different is by definition
to get out of your comfort zone a little bit.
So if there's that tingling, it's gonna push up
against the little bit of a fear response.
And so like decoupling that or figuring out
where you sit with all of that,
I think is a very subtle art.
Yeah, it's like when I first started writing
these emails that ended up
culminating into this book,
"Knowing Where to Look," you know,
I had been receiving Seth Godin's emails forever.
And then there was another friend
who you probably know, Jeff Kober,
from the recovery community,
a meditation teacher.
And he'd started writing these daily emails.
And I was like, oh man,
the thought to write a daily email just kept percolating.
And then eventually I decided, okay,
well I need to take this thing seriously,
but I'm gonna run out of content after like three weeks.
There's only so many stories that exist in the world.
And I had already written my book,
so I'd already like thought about
a lot of stories for my first book, "The Inner Gym,"
which we talked about on this podcast many years ago.
And so, yeah, the fear was there
and the fear was just as intimidating
as the idea was inspiring.
And, but again, you know I just had to start
and sure enough after two or three weeks,
I ran out of content,
but then something really interesting happened
that I would never have discovered had I not started,
which is from showing up every day,
and Steven Pressfield talks about this,
this sort of muse-like
creativity started to kind of come through me.
And I was like, wow.
I literally would be
having to hit the send button in 10 minutes.
And I had been sitting there for two hours
trying to think of something interesting to say.
And then in the final five minutes
it would like come through me,
and I would write it down and you get this feeling,
okay, this is it.
And then you would send it out.
And the next day, same thing would happen.
Maybe you have a little more time,
but I just realized that
if you keep showing up
you don't have to figure out what to do,
you just have to make the space for it.
It's kind of like that story I told about,
I don't know if you remember the Moses story,
but it's one of my favorite stories in the book,
where it's a biblical story,
where, you know we think about Moses
as this kind of charismatic leader of the Hebrews,
and, you know, he went and faced Pharaoh
and all of these things.
But the reality of that story,
according to historians,
was that Moses was a reluctant leader, right?
When he was at the Burning Bush
and got the message from God to go to Pharaoh
to demand they let his people go.
So Moses hesitated.
He was like, he didn't want to do it,
because as they have now identified it,
Moses had a speech impediment.
So he was a stutterer.
So this stutterer who had never been
in a leadership position in his life
is being told from God
to go to the most powerful, most dangerous person
in the entire land,
and make a demand on this property.
Tell him to give his property away.
So you can imagine,
his first reaction is, you got the wrong person.
You know, and God's like,
no you're the perfect person for this,
because you have to rise to the occasion.
And so then Moses asks the most sensible question
that anybody would ask in a situation like that,
which is, let's suppose I were able
to get in front of Pharaoh, if that's even possible,
which it's probably not,
but let's just run this hypothetical out a little further.
What would I say?
And God said, don't worry about that.
Just get in front of him, and then you'll know what to say.
And that's kind of it, you know, that's the path.
like you want the whole blueprint,
and it's like, no, no, no, no, just take the first step.
And that's exactly what happened to me.
I started writing these things.
I didn't, I knew I was gonna run out of content.
I didn't know what I was gonna say after that.
And, I would just had that message inside.
Just write what you know now,
and then you'll figure out what to say next.
Right, yeah, you have this quote,
something about,
that's profound, something about how
the next steps aren't revealed
until you take the first step.
And I think we're all victims
to one degree or another of analysis paralysis.
We want to know what the map looks like in its entirety
before we even begin,
and so we never get out of the starting gate.
And I know this,
all the things that I've created
started with taking a step
and having no idea where it would head,
but having on some level some trust
that if I take that step,
that that next step will present itself,
and it's never failed me.
And I think also,
the lesson in what you just shared
is this idea that it's a witch's brew
or this recipe between practicality and mysticism.
Like the practical aspect of showing up every single day,
provides the space for the mystical unknown to enter,
and that's something Pressfield talks about all the time.
There's also shades of 12 step recovery.
Like when you get sober,
the prospect of never drinking again
is completely overwhelming.
And you're continually told time and time again,
you don't have to worry about that.
You just have to hit the pillow tonight sober.
You show up for the page.
What's my daily email going to be today?
I don't have to worry about the fact
that I've committed to doing it every day.
I just have to get this one thing done for the day
and trust that tomorrow when I open up to the page
that something will inspire me.
Yeah, it's a momentum game 100%.
And that's how this podcast started.
You know, when we talked about it before on my podcast.
You went to that warehouse in Hawaii
and just kind of let it rip.
There was no, I was like,
am I going to do a second one?
I don't know.
Like, this was fun.
Let's see where it goes.
But you learned about the sound,
you wouldn't know what to even think about the sound
until you actually have echo-y sound in the first.
Yeah, like I didn't know
that I probably shouldn't record this in a warehouse.
(laughing)
Or how am I gonna put these quote, you know,
these little monologues on Instagram with captions
that look all fancy like these other people do.
Well, I don't know.
I guess I have to just film something first
and there's this thing called the internet,
and there's seems to be a lot of answers on that.
Yeah, it's not like, you know, the answers may come,
if you don't do the work.
You actually have to do the work.
That's the requirement.
Yeah, you say, I love your quote.
Like "the work is the shortcut."
You know?
We're all looking for a way to avoid that,
but the work is the means
by which you find the answers to which you seek.
Just committing to taking those first steps
that's the shortest route.
We'll back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast,
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy
my latest book, "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of
some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show,
and copious wisdom shared therein,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP,
and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only, and exclusively available
on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally direct
to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more,
and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's rich roll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
There is a sort of precarious aspect
of stepping into this world of self-help,
and grappling with the ideas of curiosity and inspiration
and motivation and discipline and purpose and passion
and living your life in accordance with your values
and self-actualization.
Like these have all become
commodified to one degree or another,
and also sort of diluted in what they actually mean.
I think the interplay between these types
of words, you know, these words in general
are getting thrown around like fairly cavalierly,
reminds me that I'm not really even sure
we agree on what they,
they actually mean, how they operate,
how they interact with each other,
let alone how to properly understand and leverage them
to move your life in the direction of your aspirations.
These are all themes and words and topics
that you are grappling with in the book.
So I think it would be helpful and instructive
to spend a little bit of time talking about that.
I've got a story in the book about
how I was in a yoga class one day,
and the teacher popped up into a headstand
and he said, you know,
the headstand is the most spiritual pose in yoga.
And I was a yoga teacher.
Like fuck off.
And I was like, what the fuck is he talking about?
The headstand.
How do you qualify?
And then I realized that his definition of spiritual
was different from my definition of spiritual.
And that was a big aha for me,
because then I realized that every time
I get into these kind of confrontations with people,
and this is important also in the race conversation, right?
When we talk about racism,
or discrimination or whatever, systemic,
people have different definitions almost all the time.
Almost every relationship fight
is a result of people having
a different understanding
of what it means to feel safe,
or what it means to love someone, right?
Somebody may think love is always being there,
no matter what.
Someone else may think love
is allowing someone to fully express independently
and then coming together
and sharing whatever fulfillment they have inside.
Like there's different understandings
of all of these really simple terms
that we kind of take for granted.
And so, again, I'm not presenting myself
as the big guru with all the answers,
to all these questions.
What is self-actualization?
I'm just saying,
have a conversation, and talk about
what your understanding of self-actualization or love is,
and then we can contrast that with my understanding,
we can find where we find the similarities,
and then we can move from there.
Maybe the ultimate solution is we have to go
to a therapist and have that therapist mediate
like our mutual understanding of these things,
'cause that's where you're gonna find unity.
Otherwise, if you'd want to try
to force your understanding onto me,
of whatever the term is,
then that's where you're gonna get
disunity and confrontation.
You're gonna create an experience
that you ultimately don't want to create in your life.
Yeah, I think that's right.
I think that's powerful.
When I think about how you think about these things,
my sense is that it begins,
like if you're on this path
towards greater fulfillment
or greater purpose,
a greater purpose driven life on some level,
that this journey is sparked initially by curiosity
and the courage to follow that curiosity.
That may morph into what we might commonly understand
as inspiration or a sense of direction, like a North Star.
And it's through that pursuit, that passion is,
or not passion, purpose, is revealed.
Is that a fair,
like characterization of kind of how you think about it?
Yeah, and I would go further to suggest,
'cause I don't think anybody knows for a fact,
but to suggest that for those people
who don't identify with a purpose,
or don't think that they have found their purpose,
I would suggest that
it's almost like the fish and water thing.
Like you're so deeply immersed
and enmeshed in your purpose,
whatever you're doing is a part of that purpose
that you can't really see it.
And that's okay,
because that's what's normally happening for most people.
And if we start thinking about it too much
it can actually cause us to be a little clumsy
with our normal, you know, living our normal life.
But, if you just keep following
whatever you can sense as your heart,
you know, a message from your heart,
and this is where meditation
and all those kinds of practices really come in handy,
because it helps you to discern between
messages from the alcohol,
from the pain body, from the trauma,
from the stress.
Or the scrolling.
Or the scrolling versus a legitimate message
from that still small voice of your inner guidance.
And again, that takes practice.
So I say, start with the little things,
find the courage with the little things, right?
Even if it's, if your heart's saying, you know,
have a salad today instead of fried whatever,
follow it that one little time,
just to reinforce it.
And every time we do that, it gets stronger and stronger.
There's no way to shortcut this process.
You have to like start listening to it
in order to strengthen it and allow it
to turn the volume up.
And then once the volume turns up,
then it becomes a lot easier to take those leaps.
But that takes time.
So patience is a requisite in all of this.
And I think, you know,
baked into that is an appreciation
for the slow evolution of these kinds of things,
and an appreciation for the fact that it is
about small gestures that aggregate over time.
And it's difficult in our culture
where we're so prone to fall in love
with the overnight success or you know,
we have this fantasy of that,
or in our scrolling we see
you got to quit your job.
And here's how I made a million dollars in a year.
Like there's all these narratives out there
that I think make a lot of people feel
either shame or guilt or inadequate,
because their lives aren't measuring up to this
fantasy version of whoever is spinning some yarn
in a short video or in a post on social media.
That's why I love memorial services and funerals.
As sad as they are,
you get reminded of what's truly important in life.
You see everyone and all they talk about
are the small gestures.
You know?
So at the end of the day, no matter who you are,
no matter how many accomplishments you have,
no matter how much money you've acquired,
or titles or whatever,
what people are going to talk about from your life
or those small moments where you allow people,
you help people feel seen and heard.
You stop, you went out of your way,
five minutes here and there.
That's what people remember.
Yeah, that trophy thing of,
it's not what you do, it's how you make people feel.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And it sounds cliche because it's true.
And I think we need to be reminded of that
as often as possible because
the social conditioning,
no matter how much we intellectually understand
that making more money is not gonna make me happier.
We all seem to still think
that we're gonna find an end run around that one.
Yeah, and we still make choices based on that,
on that hypothesis.
Mostly subconsciously because that's the society
we've grown up in, this sort of casino,
capitalist society of zero sum.
You know, I need to make as much as possible
because no one's gonna look out for me,
and blah, blah, blah.
And that's, I'm not anti-capitalist,
I'm not anti-profit,
I'm not anti-success.
That's not what my message is.
I'm pro following your heart
while you're doing all the other stuff, you know?
And if you can put as much focus and attention on,
on following your inner guidance,
what you're gonna find in my own experience,
what you're gonna find,
is you become more fulfilled as a person,
and then that inner fulfillment
starts to drive the agenda.
You start to take jobs,
you start to engage in relationships and friendships
based on what you feel inside, right?
Which is, I'm already complete.
So I'm just doing this because this is a great outlet
for the fulfillment
that I can tangibly access inside,
and it changes the why,
it changes why you do the things you do.
It's not to get happy.
It's because you're already fulfilled inside.
And again, when I'm talking about these terms,
fulfillment and happiness,
I'm not talking about binary terms.
I'm talking about on a spectrum, right?
Somebody may be at a five on a scale of 10 to fulfillment.
Someone else may be on a seven.
Someone else may be on a nine, right?
And so, wherever we fall on that spectrum,
that will determine the extent to which
we can make those kinds of more powerful, expansive choices.
So if you only,
if you're at a five, then that means maybe
half the time you can make that courageous choice,
and the other half of the time you succumb to the fear.
So really the game is how do I raise my baseline level
of happiness or fulfillment, right?
And again, that's where I loop back around.
And I talk about this a lot in the book,
back to meditation, like you can't ignore
that sort of foundational inner work,
and it doesn't have to be seated, eyes-closed meditation.
It could be journaling, could be gratitude exercises,
could be volunteering,
like some kind of inner work is almost required.
We'll take the almost out of it, it's required,
in order to raise that baseline level.
You can't ignore that and be happy at the same time.
That's the premise by which
I'm presenting all of these stories.
Yeah.
People don't want to hear that.
No!
You know what I mean?
Just give me the good stuff.
Drink this shit, drink this and you'll be happy.
Yeah, just give me the thing
that's gonna get me the thing that I want.
Like, I get all that, that's fine.
Or, you don't understand my life.
Like I'm working two jobs, I got kids,
you know, like that just sounds,
that sounds cool, I'm happy for you, Light.
But I'm already, you know, tapped to the gills.
And so I guess in the next life, right?
So how do you communicate with somebody
who feels trapped in that way,
in a very real way?
Yeah, well look in the recovery community.
What do they say?
Sometimes you gotta hit rock bottom,
in order to appreciate making different choices.
And unfortunately, and maybe fortunately,
a lot of people are on that path, right?
And the path is the path like it's,
nobody wants to go see a movie where
the protagonist only has great things happen to them
and then the movie ends.
You want to see the full trajectory.
You want to see the low moment.
You want to see the rock bottom.
You want to see the self doubt.
You want to see the redemption.
And so we're all kind of in our own version
of that hero's journey.
And so knowing you can't go wrong.
That's the great news about it, right?
Whatever your belief is about what I'm saying
about what you read somewhere that you've dismissed,
you can't go wrong.
That's a part of the story.
And that's what's so great about it.
You know, whether it's a traffic jam
or someone sideswipes your car,
someone, you know, gets sick.
Like that's a part of your story.
And all I'm saying is if you can be open to the fact
that there's some opportunity there,
whatever it is,
then it will gift you
with some insight that you would not have had otherwise,
that could help you bring about
the things that you feel are,
you're being blocked from.
Because if you're in that situation where you're thinking,
okay, I don't have any time to think, or space to think,
about any of these kinds of really highfalutin
you know, self-actualization concepts,
then it's usually, you see your job,
or you see your family situation as the obstacle.
And as our friend Ryan Holiday says, you know,
the obstacle is the way,
but you have to be open to that as a possibility.
So, I just want to help people look
at that differently, that's all.
The other big stumbling block,
and you've spoken about this quite a bit
is the inner critic, you know,
that keeps people from even getting out of the gate,
or even contemplating the possibility
that change is available.
Yeah, and look,
I don't want to sugar coat any of this stuff.
That's a really, that's a real thing,
your inner critic is a real thing.
And what I'm doing is I'm showing you
that it didn't come out of nowhere.
Like the inner critic develops and gets cultivated
over many many years in many instances
of reinforcing that belief.
And so in order to really overcome it properly,
we have to do the opposite.
We have to reinforce a different type of belief,
and we have enough empirical evidence,
enough experience for ourselves
that there's some light at the end of this tunnel,
then if we keep moving in that direction,
then eventually we will be able to contend
with the fear and the inner critic,
and all those other things that are kind of stopping us
from accessing our full potential.
And so I just,
that's the whole idea of these stories
is just to kind of chip away
at the critic and all those other inner voices
that we all have inside of us.
Like I have them, you have them,
whoever's listening to this has them.
The only difference in someone
who seems to be on their path,
and someone who feels like lost,
it's not that that person is less busy
or less fearful or any of those things.
It's just that person has usually
challenged those small moments,
where the inner voice seems to be driving the agenda.
And they've experimented
with a different choice long enough,
and held in there long enough
for some new insight to take shape.
Sure, and that requires awareness plus courage,
but developing those always goes back
to getting quiet, right?
There's no end run around this inner work,
because if you're not consciously aware
of how you're operating in the world
and responding to the signals
and the stimuli that are getting thrown at you,
then you're incapable of seeing the broader patterns
that continue to play out in your life
that then you know, prevents you from being able
to create that new narrative,
to understand when it's the critic that's creeping up,
or the fear response
so that you can make a conscious choice
to behave in contradiction to that.
Yeah, and I would give your audience credit.
I'm sure no one listening,
I mean, you know, there very few people
listening to this particular podcast
who aren't at least a little bit open
to that different sort of path,
just from your own personal story, you know,
and transformation.
And so, yeah, it starts with awareness,
and that's all I want to do is help people become aware.
I don't have everyone's,
there's no one size fits all solution to any of it,
but we do have to be at least aware
that there are some inconsistencies
in what's happening to me,
and the way I feel about it in life.
That can find more symmetry or synergy
within that, at least mentally,
starting just mentally, like shifting,
like I really had to work to shift my,
when I first saw my rental car sideswiped
I really had to, because I didn't get the insurance.
Oh no!
My credit card should cover it, but,
I have to literally, I have to work on that.
That'll throw anyone off their game.
Yeah, exactly.
And it ends up ruining your whole day,
but then if that happens, what are you missing out on?
If you let that, something like that ruin your whole,
the rest of your day or week or whatever.
Yeah, how are you so easily relinquishing your power?
To some external events.
But it's asy to do.
If you're dealing with racism,
and you're dealing with a boss,
that's like not understanding you or is incompetent,
and then you're dealing with something like that.
And that was the-
If I can't pay it.
Or if you do pay it
then you're not going to be able to pay your rent.
These are like cascading things
that create a lot of chaos.
That's what we talked about with "The Inner Gym,"
which is like building up the inner muscles
to be able to, to contend with that.
Otherwise it feels like running an ultra marathon,
and you've never even ran around the block before.
Yeah,
it's really true.
And again, these things are subtle.
They're whispers.
And if you don't have that quietude,
or you haven't cultivated
or finely attuned your awareness
and you're just ping ponging through life,
reacting impulsively to everything
that's getting thrown at you,
you're gonna miss the miracle,
is essentially what you're saying.
And you have, within many of the stories
throughout the book,
there are examples of little gestures
that end up being very meaningful
in a way that you wouldn't suspect from, you know,
the kid who was gonna jump off the bridge,
and has a brief encounter with a stranger
that literally, unbeknownst to the stranger,
altered this person's life.
It is things like that,
that are the most meaningful.
You told the story of Moses.
We all want God to talk to us directly,
and tell us what to do.
And it just doesn't work like that.
Or, or, God is talking to us all the time,
from within, and you know,
we're reacting like Moses initially reacted,
but you know what happens if we do the opposite?
Kind of like the Jerry Seinfeld story of,
that episode when George Costanza
complains that his life is just in shambles
and Jerry says, why don't you just do the opposite
of everything you've been doing?
And he does the opposite, and his life turns out to be
wilder than his imagination ever was.
And so, those kinds of lessons
I think we just need to hear over and over and over,
and in as many different ways as possible.
Yeah, contrary action.
That's what you hear time and time again in 12 step,
it's like, well my impulse is to react in this way.
And it's like, what happens if you do the opposite?
Because we already know what happens
when you do it that way.
You've got a lifetime of that and it doesn't play out well.
So why don't you try this?
Like, oh, that doesn't feel right at all.
Yeah, well, it's a muscle.
And the cognitive dissonance is so strong, you know,
like I was talking to a friend of mine today
who came up with this sort of,
what I thought was a harebrained idea,
but he had already convinced himself
that this is what he needed to do.
And, you know, I've gotten better, because I'm not perfect,
I've gotten better at just saying, okay,
let's see what happens in that situation.
And, you know, people have to kind of
run their own research and experiments.
And with the understanding that you, again,
you can't go wrong,
because even if you arrive at a destination,
that isn't what you ultimately wanted,
now, you know, you have another,
you have more evidence that this is not the way, right?
And it may take accumulating all this evidence
in order to finally be open to this other way.
So that's why I say, you're already on your path.
And your path may have to take you through these-
Twists and turns.
The universe is always knocking.
And those knocks are, you know,
kind of guard rails that are set up,
and you you bang up against them.
And those are little light knocks.
Like, hey maybe that wasn't the right thing to do.
But if you continue to ignore those signals,
in my experience, the universe starts knocking louder,
and louder and louder,
until some cataclysmic event occurs
that finally gets your attention.
And it's only in retrospect that you realize
like, oh, you know,
it was trying to tell me all along,
like I could have gotten off this train
way back there and spared myself all of this pain,
but it takes what it takes.
Pain is a great motivator.
And when the pain of your circumstances
exceeds the fear of getting out of your comfort zone
and trying something different,
that's the space where real change can occur.
And that's the power of not numbing yourself,
not numbing the pain, the pain is useful in that way,
because it can help you make different choices.
Whereas if you numb the pain,
you tend to make the same choices.
Which is at odds with all the cultural signaling
that we have, which is that
we should be pain-free all the time.
We should always be happy.
If you're not feeling that way
there's something wrong with you.
Here's a medication.
Yeah.
So, you know, we have a lot of work to do, right?
How has, you know, as somebody who's been practicing
and teaching meditation for so long,
how has it evolved?
Like, what is your perspective on it now,
since the last time we spoke,
particularly in terms of like this, you know,
rather unique year that we've all experienced.
Yeah, I think this was the pop quiz, you know,
like we got the lesson.
You should be meditating,
you should be doing your inner work.
And for those of us who kind of took that seriously,
I think this year was an opportunity to really
go deeper into that,
and for those of us who kind of, you know,
didn't study for the test, it was like
just like it was in school.
Like, you felt overwhelmed,
you felt unsure of yourself,
but you made a point to to go back and
take a peek at the lesson,
'cause then, you know, the test
is gonna repeated again and again and again until we get it.
So on one hand, I think that,
again like all these quote unquote bad situations,
there is some value and opportunity
in even in the pandemic.
And if,
hopefully you were able to,
to find something within yourself
that you could help to improve
or to build, or, you know, or to work on,
and/or help someone else, if you're already feeling complete
then you were able to use that
as an opportunity to help other people.
And I really do feel like
ultimately our life must be
about service in some capacity.
And so, you know,
whether we're serving ourselves,
self-care, whether we're helping others,
whether we're helping our community,
we have to make that a part of the daily agenda.
Not just how can I, you know,
invest in more crypto for the sake of making more money
so that I can be more comfortable.
Like the whole comfortable approach to happiness
is really backward in my opinion.
And it really needs to be about how can I use
whatever I have to the highest advantage
of the people who are within my circle of influence,
which everyone has somebody
who's in their circle of influence.
And that could be through writing,
could be through speaking, could be through posting,
could be through whatever means speaks to you
the loudest at this moment in time.
But I think that's what those kinds
of opportunities are for.
And it also exposes where we are living our lives
most unsustainably and feeling,
and perpetuating a sense of disconnection
and disunity with one another.
So, you know,
there's some opportunities within that as well as a society.
And I'm glad that that's become a part of the conversation.
What you said makes me feel hopeful.
But then I look at what's going on.
I see the divisiveness, I see the pain,
I see very real suffering.
A lot of people who are struggling,
and in meaningful ways with the challenges
that they've been presented with.
How do you grapple with, you know,
what is your perspective on
humanity's ability to emerge out of this situation?
Or just in general to thrive in a new and different way?
Yeah, we're in phase one, you know.
Like if I came in here for this interview
and I was like, rich, you know,
you did X, Y, and Z to me.
And you're like, what are you talking about?
I didn't do anything.
I don't know you like that.
And that's, those kinds of conversations
are happening with people where, you know,
you have one group of people who are feeling accused
of something that they don't feel
that they are directly responsible for.
And another group of people who feel victimized
or feel abused.
And so they're going through the stages of grief.
And so that's gonna create contention, you know,
in the middle, and you'd have to,
we have to move through that.
It happens with everything, it happened with me too, right.
It happens with all these different movements
where we kind of go in these extreme ways in the beginning,
but then eventually we kind of come back to the middle,
and we try to find unity in the middle.
And I think it's a good reminder that we're a lot more human
than we probably imagine ourselves to be.
All of us are, which is a good thing too,
'cause we're, I mean, we pulled the lens back further.
We're just animals, we're animals, who can think about
the future and the past more than say a monkey
or a dog or whatever can,
and we can organize a little bit better
than most other animals.
We're not, I mean, it's still
an argument of whether we're the most
intelligent creatures, right?
If you look at the way we treat each other,
that comes into serious question,
compared to whales and dolphins and you know,
things like that.
So,
I think this is a great first step.
At least we're talking about it,
because before this you had a whole segment
of the population who were feeling abused,
and there was no one
to talk to about it except for themselves.
So now we're talking about it,
and maybe by phase four or five,
you'll start to see a lot more unity
in these conversations instead of a lot of defensiveness.
Yeah, I mean, the manner in which change occurs,
transpires, is super interesting.
These changes always end up happening in the middle
through conversations of people
slowly coming together
and trying to identify what they actually agree on,
and concessions are made and all the like,
but the movements themselves are usually catalyzed
by people who don't want any,
have no interest in the middle.
Like they, it's through a very loud voice
that's taking a very intense stand
on a particular issue
that tends to garner people's attention,
and create the conversation in the first place.
So it's almost like you need those voices.
You need people who can do that, are willing to do that.
And then you need the negotiators,
and the the people in the middle as well.
I think it's like all voices are required.
Also if you look at Hollywood,
if you look at just media in general, right?
And I don't know this for fact,
but I'll just guesstimate
that maybe 90% of the stories that are told
are pretty much all about white people,
in every conceivable situation.
White people in space, white people in the future,
white people in the past, white people, you know,
doing all these things.
So naturally it breeds empathy for people,
white people in different situations,
but there are not that many stories about
the so-called other, about brown people in space.
No one's seen a movie about some black person on Neptune,
fighting with Matt Damon or something like that.
And so there's not,
it's harder to relate to these other people,
if your story is being told in every which way possible.
And then these other people are saying,
well, I'm just like you.
And it's like, well, you know, okay.
But I think what's happening now, which is great,
is that Hollywood is telling more stories of other people.
And the more we hear those songs,
the more we see those movies
and television shows and narratives,
the more people will start to relate
to these brown and black people
in all these different situations.
I think probably that is gonna bring us
closer together faster,
than just telling someone,
hey, I'm like you and I have these,
I'm human just like you, I have these dreams just like you.
And then having them kind of use their imagination.
We're a society, we have to actually see it.
We have to feel the empathy in that situation.
And then we kind of embody it in our life.
And I know you did a, you did a podcast with Ava DuVernay.
Is that something that you talked about with her?
I haven't listened to that yet.
Yeah, you know she talked about,
she's got this initiative called Hooray
where she is bringing more brown and black people
to the crews of these films.
So she's actually really passionate,
'cause she's obviously a director,
and she's done some wonderful work
in documentaries and film.
But in most of Hollywood productions,
even if it's a black movie,
the people behind the scenes are not mostly black,
and that can make a difference as well,
in the way that black people are filmed.
Like literally director of photography
may use different filters to bring out
the beauty and all of the nuances
of people with darker skin,
and those kinds of considerations aren't usually made in
in the executive suites of these studios.
So the more diversity,
and that's a big conversation now, as well,
is the more diversity you have in the boardroom
and the C suite, in the production,
the more valuable the product, the end result becomes,
because it's really speaking to more people.
So you're able to do more
of what you already want to do,
usually which is make money
and have influence and have impact.
You able to do more of that
by being more inclusive.
So that was kind her general message.
Yeah, and you're creating role models
within those communities
that lead to other-
(talking over each other)
And her story is awesome, man,
because she didn't start directly-
She was like a publicist, right?
She was a publicist.
She had a very successful publicist firm, a PR firm.
And then when she was 32,
she was on the set of "Collateral"
with Tom Cruise and Jamie Foxx.
And she said, you know, I could do this.
Michael Mann was directing, saying, I could do this.
And she started in her off time and weekends, holidays.
She started making these little short films,
and then that cascaded into her making a first feature.
Curiosity leading to tiny action.
She took the leap of faith, exactly.
But it started really small for her.
And she was like uniquely qualified to do the kind
of work that she was doing.
And that's just kind of going back to our original message
is that's what I'm telling people is that
you have some unique qualifications
that only you can do, and no one else in the world can do,
but you have to follow the inner blueprint
in order
to unveil them for the world.
It's like Ikea instructions,
like it looks confusing when you first look at it,
but if you just take it step by step by step,
and it all kinda comes together, and only you can do it.
But the difference would be
when you get the Ikea instructions,
all the instructions are there,
so you could read through them all the way to the end.
But in this case, you just get one instruction,
and trust that the next one,
when you complete it, there will be another one.
Right, and it may not,
you may get it underneath the toilet,
or you may get it
on the roof.
And it might be
in Swedish.
It might be in Swedish.
And you won't be able to read it.
Yeah, but you have to go to an interpreter,
and that interpreter ends up being your fiance,
'cause you know, you have a connection and it's like
everything is so beautiful.
It's almost like a beautiful-
Yeah, it's like a beautiful little game
that all kind of comes together, a puzzle.
But when you look back at the end of life,
and that's what I love about what Steve Jobs said,
you can't connect the dots, looking forward.
You can only connect them looking back.
When you look back at the end of life,
everything kind of-
It's crazy how that works and the older I get.
Everything connects.
And I reflect back and I'm like, it all makes sense.
And when you're in it, it's utterly confusing and baffling.
And it makes no sense.
And you think you're the only one who's confused,
but when you get older, you realize everybody's confused.
Nobody knows what they're doing.
Nobody.
And that's another great thing about the pandemic
os it exposed the fact that even at
the highest levels of government,
nobody knew what they were doing.
You know, we're all just-
(talking over each other)
You just think like the adults,
they know what they're doing, they're in control.
They got it covered.
I was talking to my daughter the other day,
and I was like, 'cause she's she's 17 now.
And I was like,
it must be so disappointing to come in,
when you first realized like adults don't know shit.
She was laughing, you know?
'Cause when you're 17, you think you know it,
you think you know it all
like I didn't hit on that part of it.
But you are developing an awareness that all these people
that you thought had things managed,
there's a lot of fuck-ups out there, too.
And that I think fuels that adolescent or teenage
sense that like you could do better,
which is great because we need
young people to feel that way,
that gives them the energy to
inherit culture and reshape it.
100% man.
Yeah, it's a beautiful system
when you really step back and take a look at it,
and everyone is necessary.
Like everyone's story counts,
no matter what it is.
Even if you don't end up doing anything
that you consider to be remarkable.
But you somehow share your life experience
with someone else that could trigger,
I mean a lot of these stories in this book
are things I've heard from other people.
Like the one, I don't know if you read the one
about the bridge, the little note that was on the bridge.
No, I didn't read that one.
In Vancouver.
So I was on a,
I was coming from a Wanderlust event
where I was giving a talk in Whistler.
And then, me and Gary Zukav, do you know who he is?
He wrote "The Seat of the Soul."
One of my favorite spiritual books from back in the day.
And he and I ended up being on the same speaking panel.
I was so excited,
because I got to spend a lot of quality time with him.
And then he and I were assigned to the same van
to go back to the Vancouver airport.
So we're in this van,
and our flights are both at around the same time,
and there's all this traffic,
this unexpected traffic,
going over the Lions,
I think it's called the Lion's Gate Bridge
or something in Vancouver.
And it looks like we're gonna miss our flight.
So that's in the conversation and in the atmosphere,
just a little tension with these people
who were like these spiritual people and whatnot.
And we're just kind of inching along,
and we get to the very peak of the bridge
and I'm in the backseat,
and I'm just kind of like, you know,
just kind of glancing around and looking.
And I'm kind of feeling,
I'm working the math on all the things
I'm gonna miss because I'm gonna miss this flight,
because I have another appointment,
and I have to, you know,
rental car reservation, all this stuff,
and I just glance over.
And then on the side of the bridge
is this little, it looks like a little note card,
that's like taped very sloppily on the bridge.
And there's this handwritten thing scribbled on there.
And I don't have the best eyesight.
I can see well enough to like get by.
But I got prescribed glasses when I was eight years old.
Never wore them, because I didn't want to have to
be dependent on them for the rest of my life.
So you get out.
So you just walk around, not being able to see well,
when you could just wear glasses?
I mean, I could see, well enough.
I could read signs and stuff, but things,
sometimes it's a little blurry
when I look at things closely.
Anyway, I see this little message,
and I take my phone out,
'cause this is what I do when you can't see well.
You take a picture of it and you enlarge it.
And so I did that, took a picture of it,
and then put my phone back in.
And later on,
we barely, barely got to the airport.
We barely made the flight.
But when I was sitting at-
What page, are you on?
This is page 104.
When I was sitting at the gate,
I pulled out my phone
and I found that I was just,
you know, how you just kill time.
I'm looking through the camera roll.
I almost forgot about that photo.
And I found it,
and you see it's actually on the right side.
It's a really small thing.
You have to pull it close to see it,
because I wanted people to have that same effect.
I'm trying to scroll with my fingers.
Right, me too.
It says, "the future belongs to those who believe
in the beauty of their dreams."
And I didn't know it at the time
but that's an Eleanor Roosevelt quote.
But I started thinking like,
what's the story behind, like who put that there?
Was it for someone who may potentially
want to jump from the bridge?
Was it for passing cars?
Like, was it for someone who was stuck
in a traffic jam on their way back from Whistler
to the airport, who would take a picture of it
and share it in their book,
and use this story to inspire people,
to make make little gestures of kindness like that?
It's a mystery box.
Yeah, but it was just like,
it was just like this beautiful moment,
that again, if I was like
stuck in the misery of this potentially missed flight,
I would not have had the space
to capture that little thing.
And whoever did it, it's fascinating to me.
Like they have no idea.
This is gonna be in a book
that will potentially last forever.
Yeah, that's crazy.
That's like, you know,
the butterfly that flaps its wings and-
Changes the weather 6,000 miles away.
Yeah, it just, 'cause it's not even like graffiti
that's gonna be there.
It's temporal, right.
it's gonna rain and that'll wash away.
But in the meantime, I suspect thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of people
drove across that bridge, never saw it.
Or if they saw it, it didn't register.
You might be the only person.
May be.
That was impacted in any way by that gesture,
that was there for reasons we'll never understand.
And now it's in a book,
and now we're talking about it on a podcast.
Talking about it on one of the most popular podcasts.
It is a lesson.
It all goes back to awareness, right?
If you're, you know,
it's that thing of, if you're bored,
you're not paying attention,
because there's just all kinds of utterly fascinating
and amazing things happening all around you.
And there are certain people who are attuned
to that frequency more than others.
I have friends, writers,
I'm thinking of a couple people
right off the top of my head
who will share on Instagram stories,
they're incredible storytellers.
And they can take the most insignificant tiny little thing
and tell the most amazing story about it.
And it's always this powerful reminder
that there is nothing to be bored about
if you are paying attention.
And that's a beautiful illustration
of that very powerful concept.
Yeah, there are no throwaway moments.
And what if all the billboards
were replaced with messages like that.
What would society look like?
You know the way I found out
it was an Eleanor Roosevelt quote,
was because I told the story,
I wrote a daily dose inspiration email about it,
and then someone replied,
that's an Eleanor Roosevelt quote.
And you know, so it's like a communal effort.
Like everyone, like that person got an opportunity
to connect that dot.
Or it was Eleanor Roosevelt's ghost.
Who knows what happened in that person's life,
and whoever else read it.
And these are curated from
the ones who, the emails that got
the most engagement, like the biggest.
So these have already been focused-grouped.
The book is like a five-year project.
Anthology of greatest hits,
of the most impactful emails.
So it's exciting to be able to share those with the world,
because a lot of those just,
that was one that just kinda came to me.
You know, I was sitting on my couch at 11 o'clock at night.
It's just like, what the hell
am I gonna write about for tomorrow?
And you give energy to these things
and then they grow and they evolve
and become something else entirely.
Yeah, and the way I'm measuring success is
someone hears that,
or someone hears this podcast,
and then they're out somewhere
and they start to adopt this idea
that there are no throwaway moments.
And they see something that they capture,
or they do something meaningful for their own lives.
And, and it just, there's a domino effect from that.
You just never know where it's gonna go,
but you know, again, in hindsight,
you can connect those dots and it's always,
it's like the,
you know, the connect the dot books
that we had when we were kids,
like it always tells a beautiful,
a beautiful image kind of appears
that you never would have seen otherwise.
And that's, what's interesting to me about it.
Do you know Jedediah Jenkins?
The name sounds familiar.
Why does it sound so familiar?
He's a wonderful writer.
He's been on the podcast a couple of times.
He's one of those people that can spin an incredible story
out of a seemingly banal event.
And he does it with unbelievable consistency,
and it's what makes him such a wonderful writer.
Like he just has, he's touched in that way,
but he just did this thing recently where,
I think, I can't remember exactly how it started,
but he was hiking somewhere in Griffith Park.
And there are these caves that are in the canyon
that are kind of off these trails.
And he either found a box with a letter in it, in there,
and then that prompted him to then
write a letter and put it in the box,
or he put a different,
I can't remember exactly the details of it.
I'm sure I'm getting it wrong,
but essentially he ended up putting
this like wooden box hidden in this cave,
and left a letter in it,
and encouraged people to try to find it
and leave a letter there,
like just say whatever you want.
And it's another, it's a similar analogous kind of example
of a social experiment in small gestures
that actually are kind of meaningful and profound.
Yeah, I'm gonna look that up.
Another one of my inspirations is
Humans of New York.
It's impossible to look at those
Instagram posts and not like get emotional,
get teary-eyed, and just hearing people's stories,
you know, just all stories.
Have you interviewed him before?
No, I'd love to actually.
I know he's done a couple podcasts,
but he's definitely on the list of people
that I always wanted to have on the show.
I think he'd be great.
Yeah.
But it's, I think there's a craving
and such a hunger for real stories,
that level of honesty and authenticity
that only comes with somebody like Brandon
who can engender the level of trust,
where people feel comfortable sharing on that level.
And people know the difference between
artifice or some kind of performative version of that
and the very real thing.
And when you see,
these are just average people walking down the street,
they're not trying to, you know,
gain followers or anything like that.
They're just being honest about their experience
and there's a universality in that
that we can all connect to.
And that's what makes us feel closer to each other,
and is a recipe I think, you know, a curative recipe,
for so much of what ails us.
I think that's our true wealth, you know,
our life experience really is our true wealth.
If we can relate to it in a way
that kind of gets us out of our own head
or our own misery,
and allows us to be able to share it,
to help somebody else see things a little differently.
Because I'm sure anybody really could write this,
accumulate these stories just from their own life.
Most of the stories in here are my personal experiences,
and they're not,
I wouldn't consider them to be any more profound
than anyone else's experiences.
I was just paying attention a little differently
in the way that was unique to me
because of my life experience.
But someone else like Brandon or whoever,
has essentially done the same thing,
or helped other people do it.
And the way that they curate their story,
and again, Brandon talks about this.
It took practice.
He didn't just come off from the very first one.
For a very long time.
Yeah, he learned how to ask people questions
in a way that draws out the best parts of their story,
the most impactful parts of their story.
And that takes practice.
You learn from podcasting,
how to interview people in a way
that draws out the best parts of the story.
Brandon, you know, I mean,
it's another example,
certainly this isn't something that he white-boarded
and thought this is going to be a great career path for me.
He was following his curiosity.
He could have never predicted
that it would hit this cultural nerve,
and that people would be so interested in it.
And now it's like this huge thing.
And when I look at your career,
what you've written about in this book,
I see somebody who is in this sort of dance with the muse,
who's in communion with curiosity
and how that translates into actions
that you take or decisions that you make.
And it's a far cry from this
more mainstream paradigm of like, what is your goal?
Like, what's the vision?
Like, what are you working towards?
Like, you know, where is this all headed, Light?
I don't really operate like that.
And I do, I guest on podcasts,
I get asked that question,
like where do you see yourself in five years?
And I've caught myself like trying to answer
in the way that I see other people answering it.
And then I have to check myself
because it's like I don't,
I honestly don't think about that at all.
I'm literally just, what's the next cool thing
that I could do that gets me excited to get out of bed.
And I'm in a fortunate position,
where I have my needs met,
and I can entertain those kinds of ideas.
But I got to this point by doubling down on that,
as opposed to, you know, being very,
tactical or planning out these things.
This is how you're operating.
You never would have imagined-
No, and if I set this as a goal,
I would have missed the mark by a thousand miles
because I would've missed out on
why it got here, which was because, you know,
I just made the decision to do what interested me
as opposed to what seemed to make sense, I guess.
So I'm like throwing that back at you.
I mean, again,
I think the best thing I ever did in my life
was following the guidance
to quit my first real, quote unquote, real job,
when I was fresh out of college.
That was like the best thing I ever did,
because I realized that
what we've been taught by society
about what you need to do is not the real story,
'cause that's where my adventure,
that's how I opened the book is telling that story.
And the reason why I did it,
and I didn't have language for it at the time,
but I just kind of looked around
and it was a great job, it was a great agency.
Everyone was really wonderful, beautiful,
nice people, you know, no drama.
I looked forward to going there.
I would be the first there to arrive
and usually the last to leave.
But at the same time I looked at the people
who had achieved the most at that place.
And I didn't really feel like anybody was
fulfilled in the way that I ultimately
saw myself wanting to be fulfilled.
And so I said, okay, well this is where this goes, you know?
And that's a process that I've kind of applied
to other things.
If you are in a space with people
and you're thinking of investing your time into that,
whatever that space is about.
Look at the people who've been there the longest,
who've achieved the most,
and ask yourself are they where you want to be,
where you see yourself being?
And if so, then that's probably
where your path is leading you.
If not, then that's probably not your path.
And it doesn't really matter what the external rewards
of being in that space are.
It's really about what you feel about them inside.
And so we talked about this on the last podcast
is that when I, many years later,
when I came across my meditation teacher, Tom Knowles.
He embodied, for me, he embodied that state of fulfillment
that I had been looking for
without realizing that that's what I was looking for.
And immediately I knew that's the next milestone,
is to learn this thing,
to help other people in the way that I'm being helped,
because it always came, it came back to service.
That's how I kind of knew that that was really my path.
And there was no,
this is 2003,
so there's no teacher trainings or anything like that.
And I wrote about this in the book.
So I just had to trust
that it was gonna lead in that direction.
I just kept coming back and showing up and helping out.
And then eventually, many years later,
he invited me in some other of his proteges
to go to India and train as to become teachers.
And that really set me off
in a completely different direction from where I was before.
But there was this trust
that I had, that I had developed,
that developed, and I was very intentional about it.
I remember being 29 years old in my kitchen in Harlem
and saying to myself
I'm gonna follow my heart no matter what.
And after watching a Chris Rock movie.
It takes what it takes, man.
No, that story is where you talk about
this idea of wiggle room.
Like, even if you feel
like you're on a good path for yourself,
like not holding on too tightly to it,
and always making room to be malleable,
so that you can be available for
the magical opportunity of going to India,
in the case of your story.
And it's not about, you know,
'cause some people may look at or hear that and go,
that's just you not committing
to whatever you said you were gonna do.
And I would refine that and say what's really
your feeling about your path,
whatever that is, whether you have language for it or not,
is always gonna be there,
but the day-to-day plans may change,
about how you get there,
what occupation or what family lifestyle choices
you have to go through in order to get there.
And so that's where you want to be malleable
and be open to inspiration,
not in questioning the ultimate goal or plan.
You really can't go wrong
if you just keep following whatever.
Sure, but you also can't expect to be smiled upon
by you know, perhaps your peers and your colleagues.
No, that takes you
completely away from social proof.
You're gonna look like a dilettante.
You know what I mean?
Like, oh, this guy just goes from one thing to the next.
He can't really like stick with anything.
Did you read
David Epstein's book, "Range?"
No.
So it's a very interesting kind of study
of a variety of people who have excelled
in different fields,
from science and education to athletics
and art, et cetera.
And it belies this
sort of Malcolm Gladwell myth of the 10,000 hour rule,
and demonstrates that there are those people, of course,
the Tiger Woodses, and people like that,
but by and large,
most people who are fully expressed
and excelling at the highest level
of their specialized field
are people who earlier in life
did lots of different stuff,
and were the people
who just really couldn't commit to anything.
And as a result,
they develop this robustness of experience
that back to that idea of in retrospect, you know,
all the dots line up,
make perfect sense with where they end up,
but they are people of varied interests
and many different passions
who develop that capacity early to be malleable,
and flexible to have that wiggle room.
And, you know, it's those people
that we look at now as lazy dilettantes
who ultimately, it's reframing that and saying,
well, and you talk about this,
like how do you suspend judgment in the book?
Like maybe they're like,
we should look at this a little bit differently.
Perhaps they're in their exploratory phase
and they're gonna be magnificent
and amazing and world changing,
in something that they finally latch onto later in life.
Yeah, there is a story in there about how
I talk about leaving that first job
for the reasons that I left,
and then while I was writing,
I remember the day I wrote that story, I was in an Airbnb.
I think it was in London,
living out of a backpack.
Didn't own anything,
still don't own anything.
I've got a little money saved up,
but I had less saved up at the time.
And I was like, eh, you know,
compared to my peers, I don't really, I haven't succeeded.
I haven't really done anything, you know,
that led to the material success
that we kind of aspire towards today,
but I've never felt more fulfilled.
And I realize that the true wealth
is the fulfillment inside.
And that's, again, this is a living experiment.
And it's not that I'm like walking around
beaming all the time because I feel fulfilled inside.
That's not really what we're talking about.
It's having an inner security that wherever you are
is where you're supposed to be.
And if that means you get challenged in certain ways
then that challenge is there for you
to learn something new about yourself.
And that, that new thing that you learn
is going to add to the feeling tone of fulfillment.
And so that's the underlying message of this whole path,
is your path is not leading you
to more success or more comfort,
it's leading you to know yourself better,
and ultimately to feel your connection with other people.
And that could be
a very very treacherous path at some points.
It could be incredibly uncomfortable at other points.
And,
but the happiness that people tend to look for
outside in success is much more temporal
compared to what you can feel inside
while you're going through
all of those other moments and obstacles in life.
Beautifully put, man.
You really stuck the landing.
I'm like, it's not gonna get better than that.
Like, we should just end it right here.
But there is one thing I want to do before I let you go.
And I think this is like
specific to anybody who might be questioning
the efficacy of meditation,
this beautiful passage, who from the book,
and for those who are following along at home
with her own copy,
can find on page 80,
It's called So Gullible.
I love this, man.
I love this passage.
So can I read it?
Yeah.
I'm gonna read it.
Love that.
I'm so gullible.
People think meditation makes you gullible
but it's actually stress that makes you gullible.
Stress makes you crave French fries, cookies, and wine.
Stress makes you come up
with important sounding excuses
about why you can't exercise.
Stress makes you think
the reason you're tossing and turning at night
is because you don't have the right mattress.
Stress keeps you locked in codependent relationships
with emotionally unavailable partners.
Stress makes you say and do foolish things
you have to apologize for later.
Stress even makes you think
you're incapable of meditating,
because your mind is too busy.
Meanwhile, meditation makes you bold.
Meditation makes it really hard to put up
with someone else's BS.
Meditation makes it almost impossible
to remain at a dead end job or in a bad relationship.
Meditation makes you stand up for others
and follow your heart with no fallback plan.
Meditation allows you to be guided by your intuition
instead of your fear.
Meditation helps you accept others and let go
of the need to control.
Meditation helps you sleep like a baby,
even though you don't have it all figured out.
While I'm reading that,
you know where my head was the whole time?
Like why am I reading this?
I should have asked Light to read this you idiot.
It's his book.
I loved hearing it though.
It was such a nice experience for me to hear someone else.
'Cause you know, it's like you live with this stuff
and to hear someone else say it in their own words,
it's like, it's a really beautiful experience for me.
So thank you for gifting with that.
This is your Post-it note on the bridge.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It's great man, I love that.
It just breaks it down into very practical brass tacks
and removes all the excuses that we have.
Yeah, and hopefully it helps other people
who come across this work,
just look at things or consider things
a little differently, like meditation,
or whatever it is that they're questioning,
and find the solution within their own life experience.
Yeah, I think the book, you know,
beautifully written, all these stories, et cetera,
they're all prompts.
This is just a catalyst to get you
to reflect upon these ideas a little bit more.
You're not saying, here's your listicle.
This is how you're gonna solve this problem.
It's like maybe look at it this way,
and then, you know,
circle back to me in a year, right?
Yeah.
Well, congrats on the book.
It's a beautiful thing.
Everybody should check it out immediately.
"Knowing Where To Look,"
with the 'where' upside down on the page,
to play a little optical trick on you.
Little optical tricks play out throughout the book,
available at your favorite independent bookstore
and on Amazon, of course,
and at LightWatkins.com.
Anything else you want to leave people with?
Continue to follow your heart,
and take leaps of faith.
And I believe in you.
I appreciate you, man.
Thank you.
The world is a better place with you in it.
I'm at your service.
If there's anything I can do to help you
or help advance your work,
I hope you'll reach out to me.
Thank you, I will.
Cool, peace man.
Come back and talk to me again.
Around four, right?
This is our third one.
This the third one, yeah.
All right, we'll do four soon.
Yep.
Peace.
Namaste.